You think you can fix me
Jean you are not broken
'This is the end beautiful friend'
the mind is a fragile thing takes only the slightest tap to tip it in the wrong direction
'This is the end'
Charles
What did you do?
I had to keep it stable
I protected her
from the truth
There's another word for that.
I came looking for answers
You feel like you don't belong here
You don't.
They can't begin to comprehend what you are
She's changing
That's what
You didn't come here looking for answers
You came here looking for permission.
Jean
She's all but arranged.
Pain
This war's coming out of us
Jean lost control but she still our friend?
This is your fault Charles
The world is on the brink, I'm sorry. I didn't stop it sooner
You're always sorry Charles and there's always a speech and nobody cares
there's still hope
Don't do this
They are right to fear me
I've seen evil
I'm looking at it now